This video is brought to you by Manscaped.com
Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show I'm your
host Paul and today we're gonna party like
it's Thorsday...even though it's Wednesday.
Episode 7 of What If is now out and throughout
the video we're gonna be breaking down the
story, easter eggs, things you missed and
also discussing what could be happening in
the future of the series.
Full Spoilers ahead so if you haven't checked
it out then check out now.
If you enjoy the video then please hammer
the thumbs up button and I'll be your adopted
brother from another mother if you subscribe
to the channel.
With that out the way, thank you for clicking
this, now let's get into What If Episode 7.
Ok so the episode is heavily based around
Thor and it reimagines the guy if he lived
the life of Andrew WK.
Showing my age there but Chris Hemsworth has
returned to the role and he brings the usual
fun that you'd expect from the God Of Thunder.
For the last couple of weeks we've been somewhat
in the multiverse of sadness and in the lead
up to this I was expecting Tony Stark to get
struck by lightning or something as he can't
catch a break.
However it does bring some levity to what's
been a very depressing season and it ends
with somewhat of an open ending.
We know from the trailers that Party Thor
will be back before the season closes out
which we'll talk about later on in the video.
As always we open with The Watcher narrating
the events of the show and those of you who've
been binge watching the series so far might
have noticed something about him.
When the character first started off in episode
1 he was simply a silohette amongst the cosmos
but as the episodes have gone on he's got
closer and closer and closer.
This has got to the point that we can now
see his full features and clearly tell that
he is basically the baby from the teletubbies.
Now if you've been following our videos so
far then you'll know that we posted an episode
concept leak that originally had this episode
as number 5 and the zombie one as number 7.
This seemingly flipped and due to the way
that the watcher appears in the opening I
think we can confirm whether it was fake or
not.
If we look at how he appears in the Zombie
episode his face is completely looking over
everything whereas here he's gone back a bit
making me think that the order was indeed
changed.
Shoutouts Filup Molina and the team at New
Rockstars who I've been talking to about this
for the last week and I think this finally
confirms everything.
I think eventually he will end up properly
interacting with the characters and that this
might break the multiverse open as he's clearly
no longer keeping his distance.
We know down the line that a lot of the characters
will be interacting and him getting closer
and closer could be hinting towards this.
Now the episode asks the question what if
Thor was raised as an only child without his
brother Loki.
It reframes his entire life so that Odin didn't
show pity upon him and take him to Asgard.
Loki was of course responsible for the majority
of issues in his life and in the first Thor
film he was the one who slipped the Frost
Giants into Jotenheim so that they could steal
the casket of Ancient Winters.
This set Thor off on a path in which he travelled
to Jotenheim and almost started a war with
the Frost Giants which saw him cast out.
He then ended up encountering Shield, defeating
his brother, returning to Earth to stop him
with the Avengers and it's clear that Loki
is the most defining character in his life.
Thus his absence sets him off in a totally
new direction that seems...well it does seem
a bit more fun...for a bit.
Now we start off in New Mexico much like the
beginning of Thor with Darcy and Jane sat
in their truck.
Similar to the opening of the movie they're
observing an anomaly but unlike that film
Dr Eric Selvig is not with them.
They're predicting this to be the apocalypse
and in some ways they'd be right...if you
like 9pm bed times like your boy Kevin Spoilers.
This is the first time that Jane brings up
Alpha Star Icarus which we learn was wiped
out in a similar anomaly to what we see in
the episode.
Darcy says 'they're here' and this is a nod
to Poltergeist namely when the ghosts came
into the home.
However here it's a different kind of invasion
and Thor has come to Midgard with the Warriors
three and sif.
Now you might be asking why this Thor can
weild the Hammer and if you cast your mind
back to Thor you'll remember that that ability
was only taken from him because Odin put a
spell on it.
Therefore it doesn't matter if he's worthy
or not as in the opening of his first solo
film he could carry it even though he was
a bit of douche.
In my Avengers Endgame breakdown a lot of
people thought that Thanos was worthy because
he managed to grab stormbreaker and push it
into Thor's chest but this was only because
it didn't have the spell on it.
However Mlojnir did and thus when fighting
Cap Thanos grabbed his wrist instead of the
hammer.
Now what if I told you that my wife calls
me Wang The Conquerer.
Well she doesn’t but she might and that’s
because for the last month I’ve been using
Manscaped’s new all-in-one performance package
4.0
Characters like Thanos, Nick Fury, Obidiah
Stane and the dude from Ant-Man...whatever
his name is, they’ve all shown us that baldness
is Powerful.
The 4th generation kit comes with the brand
new Lawn Mower 4.0 body trimmer that provides
a shave so close people will think Razor Fist
did it.
The lawn mower 4.0 is the sleekest electric
trimmer Manscaped have ever released and not
only is it waterproof but it comes with advanced
skin safe technology that provides a shave
more stylised than Tony Stark’s beard.
It also has a super smart, cordless charging
system that gives you power for 90 minutes
and LED lights that make it look like it’s
powered by the arc reactor.
It also comes with a really cool travel lock
feature that you can engage by rapidly clicking
the main button 3 time and it’s one of the
best electric razors ive ever used.
On top of this the pack also has two products
I didnt’ even know I needed until now and
that is the crop preserver ball deodorant
and crop revivor ball toner spray.
Simply apply the crop preserver after a shower
for all day body odor protection and use the
crop reviver on your infinity stones any time
of the day.
Now I’m gonna be honest, I’ve got a big
nose but the weedwacker helps get those nose
hairs right at the back of my beast of a snout.
It’s got the same skin safe technology that
the lawn mower does so you don’t have to
worry about it cutting or tugging on sensitive
hairs.
Now for a limited time only if you get this
and two free gifts including anti-chafing
boxer briefs and a travel bag that puts a
suit of armour around your kit wherever you
go.
Go to manscaped.com and get 20% off plus free
international shipping plus the two free gifts
when you enter Heavy20 at the checkout.
The link is in the description below and just
enter Heavy20 at the check out for this life
changing kit.
Much love.
Now we cut back to Asgard to find Odin extremly
weak in a bed much like how he was in Thor.
Due to the Frost Giant attack he was powerless
to stop Loki whereas here it just seems like
he's taking part in the Odinsleep.
We find Frigga at his bedside and she leaves
the kingdom telling him no parties...which
if you've ever been a teenager means...have
a party.
It's basically your parents tellign you to
have a party.
Thor is clean shaven throughout this episode
and I think this is done on purpose to show
he's not trying to live up to his father's
image as much.
Odin of course had a beard which Thor also
did and it made them look very similar.
Maybe Thor just never had the time to shave
in the saga anyway as he was pretty always
doing something world ending so the fact that
he's beardless here makes me think that he's
had a much quieter life and therefore has
had time to do it.
Or I could be reading into it too much and
they've just done that to differentiate the
characters.
Moving on.
She says Heimdell will be watching and this
is of course a nod to his eyes which can see
everything.
He's basically Santa Claus but minus the banter
claus and he won't be letting any parties
go on under his watchful eyes.
Together with the warriors and sif Thor travels
into Odin's treasure room and in the background
we can catch the fake Infinity Gauntlet.
When the MCU first started out many people
thought that this was the real one so were
wondering how the Infinity Stones were off
somewhere else however it was quickly debunked
as being legit due to it being for the wrong
hand.
The party rages on on Earth and in the crowd
you can spot the back of Yondus head.
It's not long until we see the Executioner
from Thor and the God Of Thunder hands him
a beer which he says refills itself.
This is due to magic and it is possible that
it's one of Doctor Stranges which we saw refilling
itself during their first meeting.
Darcy and Jane go back and forth over whether
to talk to Thor and we then get a cameo by
Howard the Duck who, because of the events
of this reality never got caught by the collector.
Jane is clearly head over heels due to some
slow mo gazing and Darcy rattles off just
how amazing he is.
Throughout the MCU saga, whenever people have
encountered Thor they've often described how
amazing he is and this is no exception, especially
with his clean shaven face.
Now this is the perfect time to tell you about
Mans...
I'm just kidding.
Now we see the meeting of Jane Foster and
Thor in this reality and rather than it being
in a desert in New Mexico like how it was
originally it's shifted along slightly so
that he lands in Las Vegas which is too part
of the region.
Foster was very much a Florence Nightingale
esque character that found and fell in love
with him but here he's pretty boasting about
how amazing he is whilst getting Skrulls to
look like him.
This of course shows his vanity as he's obsessed
with staring at himself through them.
Jane taps him on the shoulder and he says
she's so Tiny.
If you cast your mind back to the Avengers
the character actually called humans Tiny
when he was under the influence of the Mindstone.
This was clearly him showing subconscious
thoughts about humanity at the time but here
he just blurts it out.
Thor doesn't even know what the Norse God
Of Thunder is showing how detached he is from
caring about anything other than himself.
He offers Jane some food and we see the Grandmaster
cutting a giant cake and the character is
once more voiced by the infamous Jeff Goldblum.
He's joined by his right hand man....or woman
in Topaz who is carrying the disintegration
stick that completely pardons you from life.
Later on we catch the Grandmaster on the decks
and this is of course similar iconography
to what we had in Thor Ragnarok when Loki
and Thor came face to face for the first time
after encountering Hela.
Topaz was too there when he was playing the
decks and ironically she died in Ragnarok
when Bruce set off the birthday song and fireworks
on the Grandmaster's ship.
Now I was kinda hoping to see a jacked Grandmaster
as we of course saw in Episode 2 that his
brother was.
However he's the same old same old but you
have to give the guy credit as he looks good
and on most other planets he'd be....so....
Now Jane once more brings up the bifrost portal
which wiped out the Alpha Star which it turns
out was just Thor throwing another party.
And what a party it is, the night looks amazing
and we watch the characters busting out dance
moves so good that even Zemo would be jealous.
Now next we see Nebula and Korg and I'm guessing
that the former did end up being tortured
by her father due to her cybernetic parts
which were not present in episode 2.
Either way she looks like she's having fun
and playing for a brand new eye and we get
several more cameos including Valkyrie and
Drax.
Turns out that you are out of luck until you've
gone duck and we see Darcy getting shacked
up with her brand new man Howard.
Now I might be reaching here but is it just
me or does the Elvis Impersonator carrying
out the wedding look a lot like Kurt Russell.
Kurt of course played Ego in Guardians Of
The Galaxy Volume 2 and it may be possible
that it's him.
We see Thor and Jane getting Tattoos together
and these are magic and science which is a
nod to the quote by Arthur C Clarke: Magic's
just science that we don't understand yet.
This was mentioned in the first Thor film
and it's nice that they reference it here.
We catch up in the morning after to find everyone
suffering from a hangover and Jane says phone
over and over in a croaky voice which sounds
very similar to ET who gets name dropped in
this episode when they're talking about what
they expected Thor to look like.
Turns out the call she made to SHIELD at the
start of the episode has come back to haunt
her and both Maria Hill and Crossbones have
been dispatched to bring her in.
Turns out that Nick Fury arrived to investigate
the party but he was taken out by Korg performing
a cannonball into a Vegas Fountain.
Amongst the quick shots you can also catch
Rocket Raccoon in the sink and it looks like
the little rabbit has seen better days.
Thor refers to him as one and this is a callback
to Infinity War in which he called him the
same thing.
Next we cut to a Helicarrier and learn from
Agent Coulson that the party atmosphere is
spreading across the globe and that it's slowly
starting to destabilise it.
Whilst Jane believes that this is Earth's
first encounter with an Alien lifeform, Shield
unveil that Captain Marvel actually came here
first and though she's not technically Alien,
she does have Kree DNA within her.
The Beeper she left with Fury was of course
only to be used in extreme circumstances and
it turns out that SHIELD are just big party
poopers.
They activate it which starts up the Captain
Marvel logo that we of course saw at the end
of Infinity War.
Back with Thor we see him taking selfies with
Ayesha aka the Golden High Priestess of the
Sovereign who appeared in Guardians Of The
Galaxy Volume 2.
This moment is interrupted by Loki who has
arrived looking a lot more like a Frost Giant
than we've ever seen him before.
Because of Frigga teaching him witchcraft
and the diet of Asgard, Loki ended up looking
very different to the typical Frost Giant,
however we see here that because he was raised
by them that this variant looks a lot different.
However the two are old pals that very much
see themselves as brothers from another mother
and this of course was very much the case
in the MCU.
Loki only really went fully off the deepend
due to learning of his true identity but not
being lied to his entire life has meant that
he's a much nicer guy.
He does have a similar sort of crown to what
Loki had in the MCU but this time it's made
out of ice.
At this point we hear a sonic boom and watch
as Captain Marvel arrives on the planet much
like how she did at the end of Endgame.
I think it's hilarious how the locations like
France and Belguim all have names that you
can see from the sky and this is of course
what happens on a map.
Captain Marvel calls him White Snake and this
in reference to the british band that were
predominant in the 80s.
Captain Marvel hasn't been to Earth really
since the 90s so this is a timely reference
for her that really shows her age.
Brie Larson, bloody Brie Larson here to ruin
everyone's day, ends up going toe to toe with
him and we see Thor put an end to the greatest
threat to the party that anyone has ever seen.
He ends up using a hammerang technique and
this might be a subtle nod to when he pulled
Stormbreaker to his hand in the beginning
on Endgame...but this time he didn't miss.
Ammiright...bloody party pooper.
Like Captain America did in the Avengers she
tells him to put the hammer down but rather
hitting it against his shield, he sends this
Cap into Stone henge.
Stone Henge actually appeared in the MCU during
Thor the Darkworld and it was the location
Erik Selvig travelled to when he went a bit
crazy.
This fight takes place across the planet and
our next stopping point is the Grand Canyon
where we see both characters duke it out in
one of the best battles in the season so far.
I love how they flyover the skyline of the
planet and it feels very Godly as they crash
into the clouds whilst thunder erupts around
them.
Thor end ends up beating her by placing Mlojnir
on her chest and this is similar to what he
did to Loki at the end of his solo film.
Thor slams her in timeout and she ends up
being branded a party pooper in a moment that
feels like it was written by the quartering.
Back on the helicarrier she brings up her
pet cat Goose but at this time I'm sure he
was still on Earth and under Fury's care.
Or she, we're not sexist here.
Now they want Captain Marvel to take down
Thor but due to her power she's just not ready
to nuke the planet in order to take him down.
Instead we need a different woman for the
job and this comes in the form of Jane who
wants to settle the situation without destroying
North Dakota.
After Loki destroys Thor's phone Jane comes
up with a plan to reach out to Frigga who'll
put an end to the party like any other parent
would.
Across the planet we see Sutur chatting up
the statue of Liberty and he says he's got
a crown too which was of course the source
of his power in Ragnarok.
However he ends up melting her arm off and
we see the destruction that he and the frost
giants bring to the planet.
They end up creating ice structures at mount
rushmore and this includes Loki crown thorns
on Abrhama Lincon and George Washington.
We jump to Sydney and see that the harbour
bridge has been turned into a dancefloor.
Now on the dancefloor we can catch Korg busting
out the robot and sucking on a pacifier.
This shot has several characters from the
MCU and next to him we can of course catch
Mantis.
Behind her is a Ravager and behind him I believe
we can catch what is a Kree Guard though his
back is turned.
There is also a Skrull and one of the errrm...fembots
from Guardians Of The Galaxy Volume 2 that
Yondu...serviced.
Think I can say that and still keep it PG.
There's also an Asgardian guard which I will
now call an Asgard and I think this might
actually be the same one that Loki immitated
during Thor the Dark World.
He did this after faking his death and used
it to take the throne but let me know below
if you think it's really him or not.
We can also catch Meek and Valkyrie and just
before Thor goes to slide down the opera house
he's once more approached by Captain Marvel.
However Jane and Darcy make a noise so loud
that it snaps Heimdell out of his slumber
and he pulls her through to Asgard.
Here she comes face to face with Frigga as
the battle rages on Earth and just as the
Nukes are about to be launched, Frigga projects
herself to the planet and gives her son a
right good talking to.
This de-escalates the problem and Crossbones
feels bad they didn't get to fire the Nukes
because at this point he would have been a
part of Hydra.
Feel kinda bad for Thor as no one likes to
be caught throwing a party by their parents.
We see Thor slowly start to become more like
his father as he wants to clean up and he
sees it as his duty to do so.
As Frigga races towards Earth he digs deep
into his powers and commands the guests to
put everything back to where it was.
This includes Stone Henge, the Statue Of Libertie's
arm, Mount Rushmore and he puts the leaning
Tower Of Piza straight which yeah...obviously
it's meant to lean.
Frigga is suspicious but with a little help
from Captain Marvel she ends up buying it.
Thor says so Tiny yet contains so much and
this is of course symbolising his arc of how
he viewed others doing a 180.
However the game is given away when Mlojnir
returns covered in markings from the days
before.
Kinda reminds me of that time I threw a party
and left one bottle cap on the carpet and
got caught.
He ends up taking Jane on a date and we get
somewhat of a happy ending until Ultron Infinite
arrives through a portal.
He carries not only the infinity stones with
him but also Visions face and I'm guessing
that this is from a reality in which he ended
up shifting his consciouness into the synthetic
body which made him unstoppable.
Now because this episode of What If has ended
on a Cliffhanger I know a lot of people will
be a bit bummed out but as we've been saying
at the end of all of our episodes, there is
hope of a teamup coming for the finale in
two weeks time.
In the second trailer for the show we could
catch several characters in an avengers-esque
lineup that included Killmonger, Thanora,
T'Challord and lastly Party Thor.
This shows that the characters are all definitely
going to be interacting at some point and
though Marvel are infamous for putting fake
things in their teasers, there is more evidence
to support it.
Last week the studio released a mid season
sneak peak look at what's to come and in that
we could catch Thor meeting with Strange Supreme.
Strange Supreme seems to be the connector
between every universe as we already know
from the second trailer that he's going to
be meeting with Captain Carter too so my guess
is that he breaks out of his reality and then
starts to unite the multiversal hereos in
order to stop a greater threat.
In this clip Thor also mentioned Zombies so
my guess would be that they pull one of the
survivors from Episode 5 and form a team with
them.
Thor has also been spotted in the teaser fighting
Ultron Bots in Las Vegas and therefore we
can assume that the leaks about the finale
being an Ultron centred entry are true.
If you saw the Hundai ad then you'll know
that showed several of the heroes fighting
against a legion of Ultron Bots and it's likely
that that is what will happen when the Season
draws to a close in Episode 9.
As for next week we are apparently going to
have a Gamora centric one in which she ends
up wearing Thanos' armour.
It could be that he was killed and that she
ended up taking on her father's legacy in
attempting to balance the universe.
We'll soon find out but I think that that
would be a pretty cool concept.
Now as for my thoughts on the episode I think
this was probably one of the weaker ones for
me and though it had a lot of cameos I just
wasn't as gripped as I was with the other
entries in the show.
I dunno if it's because I'm a DC head at heart
but I just love dark concepts and Infinity
War is my favourite MCU movie because it takes
a lot of the fun elements and subverts them
for a real gut punch.
Those are probably why I love the darker episodes
of What If but this was still pretty good.
I know a lot of people have been saying that
the Tone of What If, namely the back to back
Tony deaths kinda made the season seem very
bleak, so if this was originally episode 5
then that might have brought a bit more levity
to the situation so it didn't feel like gut
punches back to back.
Obviously we don't really know but it's led
to the series feeling a bit depressing.
Which is pretty much exactly how you feel
on a Wednesday.
Anyway that's pretty much the video and obviously
I'd love to hear your comments on the episode
below.
We're running a competition right now and
giving away 3 copies of the Zack Snyder DC
Trilogy on the 30th Of September.
All you have to do to be in with a chance
of winning is like the video, make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the episode.
We pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so message me @heavySpoilers
if that's you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of perfect
scene in Spider-Man Homecoming.
We break down the entire thing so it's definitely
worth checking out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time.
Take care, Peace